no hubo una gran multitud esperando la
apertura de la primera tienda física de
meta pero los congregados asistieron con
entusiasmo
si este edificio será el primero del
estilo del apple store es histórico y
somos los primeros clientes estoy muy
emocionado y orgulloso
la tienda está en burlingame california
cerca de los laboratorios de meta que
desarrollan los hardware de realidad
virtual y aumentada en exposición sus
últimos productos como cascos inmersivos
y gafas de realidad virtual
en nuestra tienda puedes experimentar
quest un portal y ravens
meta quiere analizar las reacciones de
los clientes en relación a sus
expectativas
yo quiero jugar a juegos de disparos
quiero ir a visitar lugares donde no he
estado antes
me gusta mucho portal porque hacemos
llamadas familiares de su tenemos
familia en todo el mundo así que es un
buen producto a tener antes tenéis para
exhalar meta y sus competidores han
invertido fortunas en tecnologías de
realidad virtual con la esperanza de
diversificar el modelo de negocio basado
en ingresos anuncios en web y
aplicaciones como facebook instagram o
whatsapp para meta en el último
trimestre los ingresos alrededor de la
publicidad supusieron el 97 por ciento
del total se calcula que la realidad
virtual y aumentada será un mercado de
500 mil millones de dólares anuales en
los próximos años y meta está dispuesta
a perder hasta 10 mil millones de
dólares este año en sus laboratorios de
realidad para desarrollar el futuro